So this is what I came up with.
Remember, this is the shape that we're going for.
I started off by drawing the outer rectangle by using strokeRect.
We wanted it to start at 50, 50 and then it needs to be 100 by 100 pixels wide.
Then we began the path.
The path starts at 75, 75.
So that just takes the pen and moves it here.
Then we move it to 125, 125, but we create a line there.
So the pen goes down and moves over.
Then we create a line up to 125,
75 which takes the pen back up, and then actually we can stop there.
With that shape, with that drawing, we can actually start to fill in.
So, then we call fill and we'll get this.
Let's go ahead and see if this code works.
Okay. I've saved the file let's come over here and hit refresh, and low and
behold we see the shape that we were going for.
At this point you got the basics down for drawing.
I recommend having some fun with it.
See what kind of cool, crazy drawings you can make and post them in the forums.